plus de carton ni de plastique dans la
cuisine zéro déchet de valérie et cyril
qui se sont lancés dans ce mode de vie
depuis trois ans il n'y a plus que des
bocaux des fruits et légumes et des
boîtes en verre qui contiennent des
produits frais on va en grande surface
on va sur le marché on va dans les
magasins bio et on amène nos vocaux on
amène aussi des sacs
parce que beaucoup de bocaux ça peut
faire lourd à la fin dans le cabas donc
du coup on prend son procès sac à brac
des sacs en tissu des sacs en papier on
arrive ici et on les verse dans les
bocaux
depuis un an la famille klein a créé le
collectif vers higuain pour partager
leurs recettes et astuces zéro déchet
pour changer leurs habitudes cyril
conseille d'y aller pas à pas faut il y
aller petit à petit je vais essayer de
faire un odorant qu'un jeu c'est de
changer de dentifrice
je vais essayer de faire telle ou telle
chose dans la dans la cuisine je vais
faire mes courses en vrac ça a été le
lot de leurs premières démarches en c2
c'est vraiment plus dans la cuisine en
étant 5 à la maison cela peut paraître
compliqué mais les thomas qui sont
membres du collectif very green ont déjà
commencé à changer leurs habitudes de
consommation
typiquement on n'achète plus d'eau en
bouteille c'était une habitude qu'on
avait avant aujourd'hui on prend l'eau
du robinet on la met dans des récipients
en verre donc recyclable consiste pour
les meubles mais toi tu on entend bien
sûr on commence déjà aussi à faire des
produits d'entretien et des produits
cosmétiques nous mêmes avec des recettes
vraiment très simple
morgane la benjamine de la famille
thomas est conquise par le zéro déchet
et le fait maison
elle fabrique depuis peu ses savons avec
ses parents par exemple les champions
ont fait parce que quand tu vois le
plastique il ya autour
et ben petit déjà et du plastique donc
faut pas trop en prendre
et quand tu les fais soi même déjà c'est
bien par du partage des trucs par
exemple pas moi avec ma maman ou papa
une prise de conscience pour ces
familles qui s'investissent de plus en
plus dans le zéro déchet il ne ferons
pas machine arrière